only when I even better
Kim Kardashian and her daughter
Northwest continue to prove their Tick
Tock Queens it's always so much fun in
honor of the beauty mogul's 42nd
birthday the mother-daughter Duo
performed a dramatic lip sync to a sped
up version of Becky Hillsong remember
[Music]
the caption mom's birthday tick tock
my
heart and I wake up and now I see your
name
[Music]
yeah Kim and North totally nailed it but
did we mention the track is about a
woman missing her ex
[Music]
Kim's still fresh off her breakup with
Pete Davidson so she might be hinting at
something here
alone
that's when I remember
but it's also just a trending track on
the clock app yep Kim says Chloe is
enjoying the sound too
that's Coco and her good pal Simon Huck
on the set of a shoot for Courtney's new
gummy line we are on set of Lemmy
doing a little secret project
Andrew
I'm not telling you what it is oh okay
well
we're still trying to find quartz but
we're on set
and before fans called out her sheer
outfit which was covered in rhinestones
Chloe makes it clear she's not trying to
free the nipple and by the way these are
not my nipples these are nipple covers
so everyone stay calm Instagram don't
ban me carry on nipple covers did such a
beautiful thing
foreign